you're paying like 4k a month what for
like a shitty apartment in manhattan you
know i'm here in new york and i'm asking
locals one question how expensive is it
to live in new york city let's talk
money
all we talk is money all we talk is
new york city is the most expensive city
to live in the united states so i hit
the streets to hear from locals just how
much money you have to make to live
comfortably in the big apple
we're rolling up on people in the
streets we want to hear what they have
to say enough of the experts enough of
the experts telling us what's going on
in people's lives you know telling us
what we want to hear traditional media
we talk
to the people
how much money do you think someone
needs to make a year to live comfortably
in new york city oh even if you make six
figures you're broke out here really
yeah look at the ice cream man yo my guy
how much is ice cream cone
four dollars when i was growing up it
was a dollar fifty
two hundred thousand or more wow damn
100 about 125 k a year at least 150 k oh
my parents pay
200k a year 75 000. how much
i'm gonna say about 120 000.
like in manhattan like a hundred
thousand more i'd say like personally i
think 130 000 150 grand 150 grand a year
well if you're comfortable means you
need space
space in new york city you need to be
able to afford it got it so i think that
the more space that you can afford in
new york city means you're comfortable
okay a million dollars
million dollars a year and uh how much
do you pay in rent i pay 1900 a month 19
what do you get for that uh i get an
apartment i get somewhere to sleep yeah
2179 for one bedroom in the bronx i'm
paying one one thousand two hundred plan
on spending at least fifteen hundred
dollars a month okay and that's like
with roommates yeah around two thousand
two thousand a month three five thirty
five hundred what do you get for that a
studio it's just a studio what part of
town downtown my rent is
1400. okay nothing crazy i live in
astoria uh four thousand four thousand a
month for me only 8.75 because i have
three other roommates and we live in
brooklyn so it's a little cheaper in
brooklyn i got it okay i live with my
family so my mom my sister and we live
in a rent-stabilized place for 3 200.
okay but we're with your family we have
four bedrooms
um
like 780
780 i'm not comfortable
okay
a major challenge affecting new york are
the residents who have fled the state
and took their massive tax dollars with
them what do real new yorkers think
about this mass exodus 21 billion
dollars of tax revenue has left new york
city do you think new york city is
ever going to die i don't think so i
feel like everyone's going to always
come to new york it's very popular
it's new york city
these people are just flakers bro
they're gonna leave and they're gonna
come back because it's new york city
everything's here i feel like this place
is never gonna die but i definitely
don't think
that it's that accommodating to everyone
no i think all the
all the locals are moving out of here
honestly it's just because everything
was shut down and i think people just
felt very claustrophobic in this city
because it is a very claustrophobic city
you're paying like 4k a month what for
like a shitty apartment in manhattan you
know i just moved here how long ago did
you move here hong kong wow yeah and i
don't know now if i've made the right
decision
well hong kong is literally the most
expensive city in the world but here
taxes they they're really like hong kong
is super expensive in terms of real
estate yeah but in new york the kind of
taxes that you pay in terms of like net
salary it's definitely worse than hong
kong really so the taxes is like driving
you nuts completely i saw my first
paycheck and i was like
i feel like a lot of real new yorkers
are moving out of the city they ain't
got the money for that [ __ ] really
period no they don't they why
because they can't afford it it's too
expensive inflation everywhere is too
expensive they move without the country
not just new york where are they going
tell me where they're going lisbon
people are going to mexico
you know people who have left a lot of
people really yeah why are they leaving
it's just
a lot it's expensive the the crime rate
covey
extra stuff and i think a lot of people
that are moving in from like for jobs or
like um school stuff like that uh those
are the ones that are moving in in the
place of the real new yorkers especially
if you didn't have like a big nice place
to stay in the center of the city like
you could vote like party by yourself
there's nothing to do nah they're not
strong enough to survive that's what it
is
yeah inflation scares people but like
we've been here our whole life no yeah
so they ran away that's it so you're
saying when things get yeah when things
get hard you got to muscle through it
talk to those people let them know
come back
show us that you're strong enough to be
a new yorker i mean there's a lot of
fake new yorkers yeah the real ones are
still here all right so interviewed a
ton of people out here in new york city
and yes new york city is expensive as
[ __ ] cost of living is no joke inflation
hasn't helped it's not cheap to live
here in new york city and even when you
are paying an arm and a leg you're not
exactly getting
a big place but that's new york city for
you on the flip side
people absolutely love the culture in
new york city they love the diversity
and they love the fact that there's
always
something to do that's why they say new
york city is the city that never sleeps
anyway i want to get your thoughts is it
worth it to live here in new york city
are there places that are like hell no
i'm not spending all that money to live
in a shoebox i'd rather live in florida
i'd like rather live in austin i want to
get your thoughts on where you think the
best
bang for your buck is or is it worth it
to live here in new york city let me
know below in the comments i'll see you
next time save that money all we talk
is money
[Music]